إنها حالة لا يتمكن فيها القلب من
ضخ ما يكفي من الدم والأكسجين لدعم
الأعضاء الأخرى في الجسم. فشل القلب
خطير ويمكن أن يكون له تأثير كبير على
الصحة ونوعية الحياة، حيث
يتمكن المرضى من أداء وظائفهم لأنهم لا يستطيعون التنفس
ويبدأون في التنفس.  التورم
والتورم بمرور الوقت يقول الدكتور إيمانويل فينيت
من كليفلاند كلينك إن هناك
نطاقًا واسعًا من خطورة قصور القلب، كما
يقول. يحتاج المرضى أولاً إلى معرفة
نوع المتلازمة التي يعانون منها والتعرف
عليها، فالأمر أسهل كثيرًا عندما يكون لدينا
مريض يمكن أن يعاني منه  يقول فينيت إن التعليم الذي
يمكنهم من خلاله فهم
ما يحدث
يقول إن معظم مرضى قصور القلب
سيتم وصف الأدوية لهم
باستمرار، كما أن تناول هذا الدواء في
الوقت المحدد أمر بالغ الأهمية، ويقول أيضًا إن مراقبة
الأعراض ومراقبة التغيرات في سوائل الجسم
وتورمها أو ضيق التنفس ومراقبة
الوزن وضغط الدم والقلب  معدل
الصوديوم والحد منه بشكل مثالي، يجب أن يظلوا
في حدود ثلاثة جرامات من الصوديوم، وأقل من
ثلاثة جرامات من الصوديوم إذا كان ذلك ممكنًا.
تقول فانيت إن الحفاظ على
نمط حياة صحي هو أيضًا أمر أساسي، مما يعني عدم
التدخين، والبقاء في وزن صحي،
وممارسة الرياضة لمدة 150 دقيقة في الأسبوع، والحصول على قسط
كافٍ من النوم، والتحكم.  مرض السكري
الحفاظ على انخفاض ضغط الدم
واتباع نظام غذائي صحي قليل الدهون
فشل القلب هو حالة مزمنة
نادرا ما يتم علاجها
أو السيطرة عليها من الناحية الصحية أنا آندي
غايثر